[Music]
so you've uh come on the record as
saying that you want to go to war with
Muslim people what do you mean by that I
say that we have to defend our um our
country our values and our people defend
if necessary with weapons Islam commands
every Muslim to take part in the Jihad
against us hey you are you watching my
videos again pause that and do something
for your first Islam net is establishing
a Scandinavian Mega mosque and da Center
in Oslo the fastest growing city in
Europe do you want to share on that
reward click the link below and donate
now you say that you're at war with the
Muslims now the way I see it yeah again
let me let me say it again we're in
Norway we respect the law of Norway yeah
everyone here respect the law I'm not
going to do something illegal you're not
going to get physical you're not going
to shoot somebody I'm not going to shoot
somebody I'm not going to slap you
you're not going to slap me because if
the former was done that would be murder
but anyway that's something else I'm
saying now you said
war you said war now I understand from
that there's only two ways you can go to
war with someone intellectually which
you attempted them fail today and
physically now really and truly
physically you're a 55y old man you're
not in any shape to get into physic but
what I will do is say this how if you
hate Muslims so much there are many
people that be willing to fight on a
legal basis with your
people I am saying today I am in Norway
there are people that you have in your
camp that are my size and my age why not
we go and fight on a legal basis if they
don't like us so much let's fight each
other let's no on a legal basis if you
hate us why not enjoy enjoy you hate us
not who brought in this hate are you are
you coward I never I never brought in
okay bring some bring somebody to fight
us on a legal basis we don't need to do
that because we know that Islam do you
want to fight or not Islam will some
Ence I'm still alive are you accepting
the are you accepting the challenge we
can do it on a legal basis no no legal
no we can no no no you go to place where
we can fight and then as you are well
aware the Muslims are
committing against no Lush Lush listen
to me listen to me listen to me Lush
listen to me you spend all day and all
night burning books that we consider we
rever we consider them holy the books
the pages are not going to come out and
fight you back I'm saying instead of
engaging with an inanimate object why
don't you engage with something that can
fight back if you want to engage
intellectually we've just done and
showed you but if you want to do it
physically get you a 55y old you get me
someone my age we'll go right now we go
to a place right now so would you accept
this calm down my friend calm down there
no no need to shout if you want to fight
we go to a club we'll fight legally
we'll go now we'll fight no problem but
you're not my weight I'll get you
someone your weight what do I say I'm
saying that you want to get somebody
that we can do a legal contract and we
can fight each other put hands on each
other how about that is that what you
really wanted stop Islam it doesn't I'm
just saying if you want to hands on us
I'm Ready I'm Ready the premise you are
trying to sell her is that we are
problem the Islam is a problem because
commands you to kill you're coward so
you can't you say you want to defend
your land but you can't even engage in
non in a legal football you are no match
conversationally or physically neither
are you and neither are you and neither
are anyone of your team you're no match
conversationally or physically you're
cowards next time you burn a book now
let me you when you're burning a book
let me just tell you something the book
won't fight back but remember that today
in Oslo square that a Muslim came
defeated you in the debate con you li
you're a you're a caveman I'm a C I'm a
liar no problem I'm a anyone
who fine fine okay you're right okay no
problem now having said that after the
intellectual decimation
discombobulation yes has been done
you've been disheveled you've been
disappointed you've been discombobulated
you have been intellectually decapitated
you're done yeah after that's it's done
now yes now after that's open I'm sorry
you are pathetic you are a liar and you
are
pathetic you know that we are telling
now all I'm saying to you is all I'm
saying to you is I want to finish this
de why you why you guys why do you guys
drive around in military vehicles
talking about defense and you can't
this guy with the headphones he's going
to knock somebody out this guy here look
how dangerous he looks any one of us are
the Muslims afraid of any kind of
Confrontation think is anyone afraid
we're not afraid bro burning a book
burning a book is not a test of your
bravery do you understand that a book
It's very effective to show not the look
of it the behavior of Muslims you behave
like killer zombies keep burning let him
speak let him speak let him speak oh he
got so angry there didn't he you
interrupting all the time now what you
just witnessed there is part of the
anti- islamophobic activism that this
group Islam net which has established
already the biggest Masjid and dawa
Center and is expanding with the grace
of Allah and with the help of your
donation is doing on the ground here in
Scandinavia now you can continue being
part of these efforts you can continue
being part of these efforts and allowing
us as the Muslim Community in the west
to be able to establish ourselves
establish our voices in a strong way as
you have seen Allah subhanahu wa tala
tells us in the Quran
[Music]
that whatever you give for the sake of
Allah Allah subhanahu wa taala will
replace it for you and he is the best of
providers do we really believe that
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala is the best of
providers do we really believe that when
we give for the sake of
Allah that that money will come back not
just that but Allah says
[Music]
that who will lend Allah a goodly
loan who will lend Allah a goodly loan
such that it can be returned back to him
in
multiplication it will be multiplied for
him can you imagine this in this holy
month how can you miss an opportunity
like this click the link below
immediately right now don't
procrastinate let's do it and send this
link to other people as well let's do it
let's get the momentum done we're
already on the front foot this is not a
time to procrastinate on this holy month